Powerful job.
Here we go.
Four,
three,
two.
Hello events or what's going on my friend.
Not much.
My man.
That shirt.
What is it?
Uh,
a moon.
Smiley face.
Graffiti and the moon.
Oh,
you know me and my smiley faces.
Yeah.
People would graffiti the moon.
That's probably the first thing I'm going to have to worry about these virgin
flights.
They're planning on people leaving some shit that you could see from Earth.
Yeah.
Pissing everywhere.
Dude.
So much to talk about.
So much going on.
There's a lot going on in the world of MMA in the world of Doug Jitsu,
your world,
mma,
even boxing.
There's a Lotta,
a Lotta shit going on.
A boxing.
It looks like we're going to get beyond deontay wilder on Monday's going to be
in here.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
He's uh,
he's saying that.
Did you see the video on his instagram?
He shows that it's more than 10 seconds.
Yeah,
it is.
It's fact.
And he plays the clock.
As soon as Tyson fury goes down and then it's more than 10 seconds before he
gets back up.
The only problem with that is,
I mean,
it's human error,
right?
You can start immediately,
you know,
there's always that little,
that little space and ties and they're supposed to be a guy on the sidelines
though.
That starts the camera.
Yep.
And then he picks it up with five fort,
right?
Yeah.
But the problem is referees,
you know,
when they're in the heat of the battle,
the fucking adrenaline there seconds.
It's not like they have a stopwatch in their hand to hit it.
Every time a guy goes down,
which,
why don't they have
Paula?
It's too much to remember.
We just talked about the heat of the moment.
Boom.
Click.
Is that too much to remember?
I mean,
think about all the Shit Tyson furious to American steak.
Right?
If you're in that fight,
I wanted,
of course,
I'm rooting for awhile there because I like,
I like big knockouts,
you know what I mean?
And um,
he looked good in the first two rounds.
Then he just looked like he abandoned the game plan and he was just looking for
the knockout after that.
Well,
he,
he's got a problem.
The problem is he can knock anybody the fuck out.
That's a problem.
Anybody except that guy said Tyson theory.
It seems like you almost knocked him out.
Like he knocked him out.
It was out.
If it wasn't.
I mean he definitely did 10.
He was definitely down for 10.
But here's the thing.
If the referee,
instead of saying eight,
said seven,
instead of saying six had five would have gotten up quicker.
I think he probably would have because he's waiting for eight,
nine and then he's standing up because he's trying to give himself.
He's an old vet.
He's trying to give himself as much recovery time as he can.
I don't know what I watched when I watched them getting up.
I look at that replay and you see his head,
his head comes up like he's trying to get up and then he just stands up like a
Zombie.
I think that's an gypsy shit.
It's scary.
Well,
I did not expect him to get up.
Um,
I would celebrate fight.
That doesn't mind.
While they were celebrating,
do the.
Was like when he went down,
I went,
oh shit,
I can't believe he knocked him out in the twelfth like that.
And it was the left hook going down.
That was the craziest,
was on the right hand that bang a left hook going down.
It was so insane and he walked off,
walk off.
It was a walk off knock out when he was dancing and he was pointing to his woman
in the audience and she was saying,
I love you.
And he was like,
the whole thing was a celebratory moment.
And then the look on his face when he realized that Tyson fury gotten up.
Like,
what?
Yeah,
you know,
you know what that is?
Remember,
remember the eighties and nineties,
the Friday,
the 13th movie when you killed Jason and then you turn around.
It's like,
Oh shit.
That fries with a full setup.
That's what that was.
How does wilder punched so hard as a man who studied martial arts his whole
life?
Like there's some dudes,
right?
Don't you think they have some frequent explosive power,
but it's crazy how much he's getting.
He's only 200,
12 pounds.
That's the crazy thing.
It's like he's very small for a heavyweight,
like a lot of these guys to 50.
Remember,
remember a guy named Mike Tyson?
Oh yeah.
He was still like in the two fifteens,
right?
He was like 2:15.
Yeah.
Not much.
Taking truck.
I don't,
I don't know how.
I mean I didn't have that kind of power,
my knockouts with from like stuff you didn't see.
Yeah.
No,
and quickness.
But like a guy like Jeremy Stevens.
It's like that,
you know,
Melvin Guillard had that kind of power.
How do you develop?
I don't know if you could develop that.
I think that's a natural thing.
Yeah.
Rumble.
Johnson type house.
Yes.
That's.
Think you can develop that.
I don't think so.
I think you can accentuate it.
I think we got hit hard with better techniques and you hit harder.
I think it's a bone structure thing.
I mean it's like if you look at a Deontae,
he's kinda built like a gigantic Tommy hearns.
Yeah.
You know,
just widen the shoulders and it's back just a fucking bundle of muscle ups.
It's just like those,
uh,
those thick ass ropes that they use for,
for boats,
you know what I mean?
When they more ships,
that's like the muscles in his back,
just jack back.
That's where the power comes from.
I guess you should let him body shot you fuck all that.
Fuck all that.
Dude.
That dude's a scary dude,
man.
Yeah.
He hits harder than anybody I think in recent memory,
like his one shot power.
It's ridiculous.
What do you think?
I mean Tyson was a better boxer.
Pure boxer too.
So,
but like I would love to see like big power punches,
like hey,
they need to make a boxing game where they,
where they have all the guests.
They might have,
I don't know,
but they need to have one where they have all the power punchers and power
puncher point of it.
Right.
Well,
you know what,
I feel like that's,
it was a perfect boxing match because you haven't Tyson fury.
First of all,
you have this guy that overcame depression and suicidal thoughts and you know,
drug addiction and alcoholism and me.
He was just obesity.
Yeah.
He was living in a world of depression,
he was just drinking constantly and doing coke and fucking his life up and then
loses more than a hundred pounds.
Cleans himself up,
gets in there against the scariest guy in the heavyweight division and puts on a
boxing clinic.
However,
he still gets clipped.
He still gets clipped not once,
but twice hard and dropped hard,
especially in the twelfth round.
So it's like for a person who loves watching fights,
it's such a perfect fight because you've got.
So first of all,
they're both great guys,
like,
like both guys like it.
If you're a fan of exceptional human beings,
both guys are great guys.
Like the more I see Deontay wilder interact with his family,
talk about things,
talk about the way he approaches fighting,
the more I appreciate what he's doing,
you know.
And then Tyson Fury,
how do you not love the guy?
And the way they exchanged pleasantries after the fight was over and Tyson was
telling me he loved him and he kissed his fucking fist.
I mean,
it was a great all around a great feeling after,
even though it was a draw,
it was like I felt good about it.
That was rocky one.
It was rocky one.
That's what that list was rocky.
It was rocky one sort of.
Right.
But it wasn't a slugger.
That one,
you know,
mean what it was was just a great.
Nobody won.
Nobody one in first one.
Yeah.
It was a great,
great boxing match.
That's what it was.
Just like,
it had all the good elements.
It was the best heavyweight fight I've seen in a long time.
I mean that,
that might've been better than,
than Holyfield Tyson.
That's hard to say because know Holyfield was like the good guy coming in
against the bad guy.
Like there was so much to that fight.
And then with Tyson,
like you thought he was invincible and then holy field just eating these shots
and slowly beaten them down and then eventually stops them.
I Dunno.
I think it's ear bitten was bite now.
That was the second one.
Second fight.
Yeah.
That was,
uh,
it was,
it was one of the best.
I'll tell you what though,
man,
anthony,
Joshua versus Klitschko was one of the best in a long time before that,
you know,
they,
they're gonna go that fella into a fight.
Someone's gonna,
someone's gonna trick that fell into a fight.
I want to see those,
that,
that threeway mix,
you know?
Yeah.
I think Joshua better stay the fuck away from wilder.
If I had,
if I was in his corner,
I was like,
going,
you get hit sometimes.
He don't want to get it anytime by that guy.
Right.
He,
he's,
he's trying to avoid it.
I mean he's got his head movement going now.
I know he's waking up
just fucking bobbing and weaving.
It's like the dudes like that.
The consequences of getting clipped are so great.
It's so.
It's so interesting.
When someone has that kind of power,
the consequences are just so great.
They're different than anybody else because you never stop watching.
You never stop watching that fight with Tyson fury.
I mean we saw the gap getting bigger in the points,
but then that knife round hit.
Yeah.
And he dropped him and he's like,
yeah,
see he could still do it and you'll watch and watch and then the twelfth round
he hit him and then you know,
if your wildest fan like me,
you're jumping up and you,
you're celebrating your,
you know,
your victory and then fucking Zombie gets out.
I'm so impressed.
Not only did he get up,
he won the remaining part of the round.
He stung wilder,
battled back off.
That can't.
Well I guess it could,
but it doesn't really happen in mma where somebody just gets destroyed or,
or dominate I guess in MMA would be like a bad beating in one round and then the
next round you'd come out and you just like fresh.
Because when he dropped him and when he get,
when,
when fury got up and he looked at him,
you know,
he was a little bit broken,
but he's probably like,
all right,
I'm gonna,
take this motherfucker out.
And then fury put it on him a little bit.
Probably not broke his spirit,
but it probably made him kind of shrink up a little bit.
Well he got lit.
I mean,
he definitely got stung,
he got cracked and you'll see him like his eyes rolled back.
He backed off a little bit and then he grabbed a hold of Tyson.
I'm like,
whoa.
He got rocked.
Look,
both guys are incredible good conditioning to.
For,
for,
for heavyweights.
Immediate.
Yeah.
For to take shots that late and that.
That's a lot about conditioning.
When you get tired,
you,
you know,
your brain is ready to shut off.
Yeah.
And to be that big,
I mean six foot nine,
256 pounds and still have that kind of conditioning,
you know,
and wilder to carry that knockout power in the twelfth after being frustrated
and just within a lot for fucking rounds.
That exhausts you,
the punches,
you miss those.
That takes so much off of.
You take so much.
Yeah.
It was just great all around.
It was just great.
What's the best?
What's the best boxing fight you can remember watching in your lifetime life?
Not,
not in person,
but just watching it as it happens.
Wow.
That's a good question.
I think Julio Cesar Chavez versus Meldrick Taylor,
a lot of people say that I didn't watch that one line because Taylor was so
good.
He was so fast and he was winning up until the twelfth round and Chavez just
kept the pressure,
and then eventually crack crack.
He had some of the big right hand.
The twelfth round,
you see Meldrick has just beaten down.
The downside of that fight is Meldrick.
Taylor was never the same again.
Yeah.
That was one beating that just.
He crossed over beyond the Pale and went to the dark lands.
It's just not good after that fight.
So what,
what do you think if a.
was it Richard Steele was rough.
I think it was.
So steel doesn't start that fight in those last seconds and Meldrick Taylor wins
on the cards then.
Then what happens is their rematch and does he look the same as he?
Was He the same guy after that?
I think if he wins the match,
he's done.
He's done no matter what.
Remember when Terry talked about after that he just did not look like he could
take a punch anymore.
That fight was so brutal.
If you watch that fight against Chavez,
just raking his
body and clip them,
but meldrick was just so fast and so skillful,
like his movement and his speed,
but Chavez was just relentless,
was a great fight.
Elizah great fight,
but watched it after the fact.
But there's a few of those fights where you know that that was the one where the
guy's never going to be the same again.
Yeah.
You,
you,
you felt that way watching it?
No,
I felt that way afterwards.
I mean watching it,
you go,
what a great fight,
but then afterwards you realize like,
oh,
that was it.
That was the fight.
I kind of felt that way honestly for MMA.
I felt that way about rory after the Roy Robbie fight who wonderboy and I was
like,
yeah,
he doesn't look the same.
Well,
I think he was having real problems with his nose.
You know,
his nose has been shattered a bunch of times and he just can't take a shot at it
anymore.
It just starts bleeding really bad,
but I think physically the way he moves and his ability to take punches is still
exactly the same.
Like you saw him in the Lima file.
It looks good still.
Yeah,
he does.
He fucked up taking them.
We saucy fight though.
Yeah,
that's us too big to too big.
I thought the same thing to,
you know.
Exactly.
I mean they have a lot of similar sales skill sets and then the bigger guy,
it's like what's the saucy?
Might be a little better to striking.
Definitely better with a striking his grounds.
No joke either.
Yeah.
Massage is just so good,
man.
He's so good that like if I was in his corner of billet,
look,
I get that.
You want to do a superfight?
I want to do a challenge.
These guys quite a bit bigger than you and really,
really fucking good.
Like when you started,
you might be the best one.
80 five are in the world.
Thinks that he's not.
If he's not easy,
he's there.
He's with whitaker,
he's with Joelle.
He's there.
I,
I.
There's a mix of them.
I really,
really like.
I have a whole lot of confidence in whitaker to quietly.
He just kind of rose up to the top and I think people still sleep on him.
I think so too,
but I got to say that I was surprised at the decision in the Yoel Romero fight
the second one.
Yeah,
I,
I think Romero won that fight.
Yeah.
Or if not one it.
It was so close.
It had to be a draw.
It was so fucking close.
But I think Romero did way more damage Ramiro.
See?
He heard him a couple times.
Think about like the wild or fight.
Like someone said to me like,
oh,
the score cards are all fucked up.
Tyson fury should have one.
Maybe.
Yes.
I see what you're saying if you're looking at it in terms of like that.
But as a person who knows what a fight is,
wilder clearly won the fight.
If it was a fight.
Right?
Who's getting fucked up right in the school yard where the one that he won.
Right.
And this is the Yoel Romero whittaker thing.
Who won the fight?
Whitaker's getting,
you know,
just he got hit with bombs by Joelle.
Joelle hit him with some fucking haymakers and whitaker survive,
but when it could never put you well in that same sort of situation where you're
well with staggering around like really badly hurt me.
You Whitaker is a champ.
I mean the,
the,
the skills,
the heart,
the courage,
all those things.
I mean he's got everything.
He's a champ,
but I felt like the damage done.
I hate the 10 point muscles.
Yes.
I hate it.
I mean so stupid.
It doesn't make any sense.
A five minute rounds you'll using 10 points.
Why?
Because it was already there.
Exactly.
That's,
that's the big thing for me because I mean we got aspects of Jujitsu,
got aspects of wrestling.
We've got aspects of striking boxing and kickboxing.
Right?
And we're using a rule set from boxing only one set of weapons.
That's it.
And like how does that,
how does that quantify the takedowns and the grappling exchanges?
It's right.
It's,
I dunno,
I,
I disagree.
I remember there were,
they had all these different systems they were trying to work and I feel like at
one point I think doc rivers maybe had Campbellton thought Hamilton.
Sorry.
Yeah,
he does basketball,
but yeah,
doc Hamilton has an excellent system.
Was that half point system right?
Which was better,
was better than what we're using now.
The pride system was better.
Yeah.
The system is better.
Chose to fight as a whole and the last part of the fight is more important than
the first Friday of the fight.
Right?
Because that kind of tells you the path that we're going on a school yard,
right?
Who's on top?
Who's on top of the teachers get there was beating the dude down.
The teachers get there.
Nobody cares if you like throw a leg kicks and boxing the guy up for 15 minutes
and then the teachers come right when the guy gets on top of you and punching
your face.
And I want the decision.
No,
no,
no.
The teachers pull that guy off you and then you get rebounds.
Rematches in school.
Fucking hard to swallow.
You gotta you gotTa have balls,
so that rematch in school.
Yeah.
No money.
All Glory.
No,
this has got to be right.
There's got to be a rematch for this fight.
It's going to be the biggest heavyweight fighter of all time.
I mean,
there's going to be Gi fucking antic and I'm happy for wilder because while
there is finally a star,
I mean forever.
We wanted an American heavyweight champion.
Yup.
Klitschko had it forever.
Now we have not only an American heavyweight champion,
but we had an American every week,
championed the knocks.
Everybody the fuck out,
knocks everybody the fuck out.
Super exciting.
Great Guy.
For some reason he didn't catch like.
It's weird like who catches who gets famous?
It's weird.
But then when you look at the post fight interviews and I'm Tyson Fury,
you know,
God bless me.
God bless you and God bless America.
I mean he got a lot of people on his side.
He's not American.
He's a good guy.
I him in here.
He's great.
I mean,
he's a real character.
He's the real deal.
Both of them are.
I mean,
I'm fucking so excited about the rematch when you think that happens.
It's got to be a long time.
He got hit with some bombs.
If I was in Tyson's camp up,
like,
do we got to take some time off so I know you feel great and you're riding this
high.
How about the guy donates all his money to charity?
Isn't that incredible?
That's just ridiculously incredible.
$10,000,000.
$10,000,000 just donated.
Is he going to do that in the rematch?
Rematch is $100,000,000
deficit.
Floyd mayweather money,
right?
The rematch could be the biggest heavyweight title fight ever.
Yeah.
It's,
I mean,
it's bigger than right now,
especially with the world,
the way the world is.
It's bigger than totally feel Tyson.
It's bigger than you.
It's bigger than Holyfield Tyson and think or right there,
at least right there.
It's hard to say because Tyson was such a cultural phenomenon,
like there was no one like him when we're kids and when Tyson would fight,
it would just be like,
uh,
watching a public executions and people would wonder,
should I pay for this?
Should I get this pay per view?
How long is it going to last?
Have a bunch of people over popcorn and shit and it lasts 15 seconds.
What,
what do you think?
What do you think the benefit of while they're having Tyson come into his next
camp?
Is Tyson him and he's a student now.
He knows boxing well.
Is he doing that?
I don't know.
But what would the benefit be?
Looked at the benefit would be great.
Mark Tyson knows a lot about boxing.
I mean he doesn't just know a lot about how he boxed the history,
but he,
uh,
he knows so much.
I mean that was like one of the big things.
Uh,
one of the big stories about his childhood was him watching Jim Jacobs old reel
to reel films that wash up.
He'd watch all those old school films.
Joe Lewis and Shit and Jack Dempsey,
you know,
he,
he liked pattern a lot of his style after watching those old timers.
Archie Moore and yeah,
I mean I think,
uh,
he could definitely help them I think.
But the style of someone who could help wilder would,
would be someone who is going to incorporate more movement and and more like
switch up.
Like don't always throw a bomb.
You know who I would bring in files,
wilder,
Andre Ward,
Andre Ward and Virgil Hill.
Have those guys tighten up what he does.
I think Andre Ward is one of the smartest guys in boxing.
How,
how is he as a,
as an instructor,
as a teacher?
He's too fucking smart to not be good at it.
He's too smart.
He knows too much about boxing.
Like he's one of my favorite analysts when he talks about fights,
like the way he breaks things down.
Yes.
You know,
and,
and he's a guy who really does find weaknesses and exploit them.
It's not just pushing buttons and throwing haymakers like if you look at his
rematch with Cova level,
like he figured that fucking guy out.
Like he,
he got hurt by him early in the first fight,
but then one the remainder of the fight.
And then one of the decision a little bit controversial but then said,
I know how to beat this motherfucker.
And then came back and the second fight and stopped him.
Yeah.
Andre Ward is and Virgil Hill.
That's old school.
Old School.
Yeah.
That's,
that would be a good fit.
But there's a lot of good fits in boxing.
Boxing is an interesting thing is that they've had this long history of trial
and error that,
that MMA hasn't had,
you know,
like you see,
you see this,
you know,
you got lineage that goes back to the sixties and seventies.
And I'm like,
yeah,
goes back
way.
Yeah.
I really pap.
Sure.
I mean in terms of like active trainers.
Oh yes.
And active gems,
you know,
I mean these guys had been around for forever.
They've been putting champions into rings for decades and there's a lot of those
guys out there.
I think about.
I think about that too with like with Tyson.
I mean like if customer auto didn't die when he did,
would tyson's career have been different?
Probably would have that.
It probably would have been different.
I mean,
I think Kevin Rooney did his best to try to keep that teaching going.
But,
uh,
I think sometimes that mentor is the glue that keeps you together.
Yeah,
that's what I'm talking about.
Yeah.
The other stuff,
that guy meant so much to Tyson because custom model essentially gave him this
new lease on life.
He thought he was going to be a loser and his life is going to be hell.
And then instead he's the heavyweight champion of the world,
the youngest ever,
you know.
But then,
yeah.
Well,
you know,
Teddy Atlas had a very,
very interesting take on Tyson.
He just felt like Tyson never developed the skills to overcome adversity.
So as long as he was dominating everyone who was great,
but as soon as it started coming back and him,
he would,
he would never recover from that.
You know,
we call that Nima me the bully or a front runner.
Yeah.
There's a lot of guys like that,
right?
Yeah.
And good on top.
Yes.
They're good.
Hammer.
Not such a good nail.
Yeah.
You got to be able to take them both.
You,
when you say hammer and nail every reminds me of like,
there was something I was thinking when we're talking about rory and Robbie,
like would,
it takes how much pain you have to be in to be a fighter,
to be a fun of Roy's caliber and then just sit down and concede.
Yeah.
Because like it hurts that much.
I think his face was shattered.
His nose was broken into eight or nine pieces or some shit like that.
It was just,
it was just mush and I just don't think he physically could go on anymore.
Like I've had.
I've had,
I've had breaks in training,
either breaks in and fights.
Um,
broke my jaw one's training.
I was like,
oh,
that hurts.
Uh,
and then I got hit again.
It's like,
yeah,
I can't do this.
Then I'm just.
Was it a clean snap?
No,
it's just a,
a hairline.
But like,
it hurt,
like I couldn't chew.
I was crying the next day.
I didn't know is broken until the next day.
But um,
and then when I fly out,
Ludwig and bang,
and I thought I was on top,
he was on his back.
He feels a punch upwards,
hits me right in the eyeball and bust my orbital.
Yeah.
You're talking about this the last time you were here?
Yeah,
it's crazy when he hit me though,
I was like,
that hurts.
Oh,
I put my head down for a second and I was like,
I got to tap this guy at a tap,
this guy.
So I'm just trying to institute a Jujitsu game and um,
he's escaping all the time.
But the pain,
it was like,
it wasn't like I went out for Laurie to sit down and concede like I can only
imagine because I've been in pain and a fight like excruciating pain is like,
I just got to figure this out and move on.
But he was just like,
no,
that's enough.
And it's rory.
We know how tough he is.
He's also crazy.
Like,
this is a dude who he,
you know,
he's like,
you just kind of expect him to have bodies
bodies on it.
Did you see him when he was on a podcast?
No,
I didn't.
I didn't see that.
He's not like you would think he is.
He's a great guy.
He is.
He's like very,
like warm and friendly is awesome.
I sat on it,
sat with sat next to him on the bus a bunch of different times and we were just
writing to their arena.
We've had a bunch of conversations.
I love him,
but when you see his,
his demeanor or his persona when he,
when he's,
you know,
in front of the camera,
he just seems very
serious,
very serious.
And that killer,
like serial killer.
He is.
He's not done either.
I mean I think the fight was a bad idea,
but I still think he's one of the best welterweights on the planet and 100
percent,
100 years.
I mean he can come,
he can come back to the UFC and.
And threatened tyron.
I think so.
I mean he,
he beat tired when the first time,
but that's a different.
Tyron,
tyron with Duke Roufus is a different time and I think,
you know,
he's just,
he knows more now.
He's a champion now.
He successfully defended his title several times and he's much better too.
He's um,
he's still slows later in the fight,
but like,
it's drastically different than it used to be.
Um,
and once what I would like to see out of Tyron is more use of all of his skills
later on and not just looking at land that big right hand because like tyron can
do everything,
tyron can do everything,
but there are those times when you see him start to really depend on that right
hand and only look for that.
And he's like,
he's like right hand,
right hand,
right hand.
The thing about that right hand though is it works
when you have something like wilders,
right hand or leg tyrants,
white hand,
you have something that can you have a right hand that could put anybody out.
I mean this is,
I brought up before,
but think about it.
He fought Darren till and they fought wonderboy twice.
Those are two,
two guys that are arguably the best strikers in the 170 pound division.
Fuck.
Both of them up on their feet.
I mean both fights.
Wonderboy was on Queer Street and then in the till fight,
the only punch landed at all was by Tyron.
Right.
He cracks till drops until Neverland touched him with a glove drop.
Some beats the shit out of him and then chokes him.
I think that was one of the best performances from tyron.
I.
He looked really good in that fight.
Really.
He looked almost like a disdainful to like,
you know,
you motherfuckers can't believe you guys got him the Fed betting favorite?
Yes.
Like what?
What is that shit going to beats.
Cowboy cerrone.
A guy was supposed to be fighting at 155 pounds.
He's tough as shit but one big fight and all of a sudden you guys have in the
betting favorite.
This is preposterous.
Put some respect on my name.
Yeah,
well he's a,
he's a polarizing figure for some reason.
I don't know why.
Maybe it's one of those things where guys have to catch,
you know,
like maybe it's like if tyron
had a GSP fight,
like if GSP comes out of retirement fights,
tyron,
tyron smashes GSP,
then maybe people go,
I wonder like what Mohammed Ali was like because I wasn't,
I wasn't there like everybody loves him now,
but did they love him when he was,
when he was running his mouth?
And like,
I'm sure people did.
I'm sure that he had um,
his,
you know,
like the economy,
greg of fans,
you know,
because he was that good.
But I wonder if there was this big contingent of people that were like,
yeah,
no,
we hate that Muhammad Ali guy.
Well,
he was really that good,
but then he wasn't.
See what happened was we got really crazy with our was they made him take three
years right off of fighting and during that three years he was supposed to be
fighting in Vietnam.
He's like,
fuck you,
I'm not going to Vietnam.
So they stripped him of his title and then he doesn't train.
I mean,
when he came back,
did you ever see his comeback?
Find,
nope,
he came back against Jerry Quarry and I'm,
I'm telling you man,
he looked like he had no muscle.
Like you look at him from the old days,
like look,
when he fought Cleveland,
big Cat Williams.
I mean he was just a Greek God,
but then you see him when he's coming back and he's fighting quarry three years
out of the ring,
probably barely trained at all.
His body just looks slower and smoother.
He just didn't look the same.
Like physically see if you could find that.
I mean,
and Jerry quarry was just a super tough guy.
Just would walk forward and eat a bunch of shots.
But you look,
you look at his body like it doesn't look the same.
See,
look it,
look at his back.
He doesn't mean he obviously went through a full camp.
Get ready for that,
but he doesn't look like the Muhammad Ali of old.
And then when he's fighting he doesn't move.
Like the Muhammad Ali of old.
Those three years took a toll on them.
Like look at his body.
Just doesn't look the same.
Yeah.
He looks a little smaller.
Smaller because he hasn't been training,
so we lost,
probably lost a lot of muscle,
just looks smoother and just doesn't look as quick or as good and he's fighting
a guy that has no business in the ring with him,
you know,
he's fighting a guy that mean and he's a jerry quarry is a sad story when it
comes to brain damage to like the end of his career,
the end of his life rather.
It was horrible.
I mean he had fought so many times against big punchers and was known for being
able to take a punch.
And then also I think coming up,
I think it was his brothers,
his brother also had like a real problem with brain damage.
I think they did a lot of real hard sparring together and a lot of hard sparring
and the gym and the end of his life was awful.
I read an article about what it was like at the end for him and it was similar
to what the end was like for Ali.
It's,
um,
I dunno,
I always,
when someone says something,
it makes me think of something else.
And you're talking about cory and his brother made me think of Joe Lozan and Dan
Lowe's on fighting in the yard when they would have those barbecues.
Beat the shit out of each other.
Like legit.
Beat the fuck out of each other.
Yeah.
I don't know if I could do that to my family.
They had a different kind of friendship.
It's so funny.
It's crazy.
Those videos of Joe on top of him punching him in the head from behind.
I'm like,
whoa.
Joe Dot.
Yeah,
exactly.
That's what I'm thinking.
It's like,
that's not a stranger.
Well,
you know,
that's some of the toughest guys grew up with brothers and they already here
beating the shit out of each other.
This is what I stick it out.
The thing is though,
this is Massachusetts.
Massachusetts is a fucking hard ass place in there fighting mean they're full
blast kicks and punches and then the entire family is watching now and they're,
they're having a real legit mma fight.
I mean,
look at that.
That's what a bunch of psychos.
They got little girls watching and shit in there on the grass and he's beating
the shit out of his brother
and he's better to look at what kind of cycle family or the
fucking car,
the whole family sitting there.
Oh Shit.
They put a soundtrack on it.
Oh,
that's hilarious.
Awesome.
Yeah,
let's not watch this.
I like both these guys got them at triangle.
Oh,
I'm about tyron though.
Like I,
I don't.
I mean,
look when,
when Ali was,
uh,
the whole thing about him refusing to fight in the draft,
like people hated him.
There was a lot of people that hated him.
A lot of people that consider themselves patriots and thought it was before.
We have to realize that now pretty much everybody thinks the Vietnam war was a
terrible idea.
Right?
The Gulf of Tonkin incident,
which got everybody into Vietnam was a false flag.
It was all bullshit.
We shouldn't have been there in the first place.
Who knows what the real reason for being in Vietnam was.
But a lot of people think that had to do with heroin and money and all kinds of
crazy shit.
Right?
So when Ali said,
I'm not fighting that war back then though,
back then people thought he was a coward.
Right?
Back then people thought he was a trader and he was aligned with Malcolm x.
He changed his name from Cassius clay to Muhammad Ali and everybody was worried
about the black panthers and the black Muslims and you know,
it was like,
there was a lot of hate towards him I'm sure.
And so then when he came back and he was not the same guy anymore,
I'm sure people loved it.
They were happy.
They were happy when Joe Frazier beat him,
people were happy.
Yeah.
That's,
that's human nature.
It is.
People pick sides.
Like you picked sides when wildin knockdown fury.
Yeah.
We pick sides.
I don't.
You mean you don't know those guys,
right?
No,
like,
I'm also not going to hate on it,
but you know what I mean,
that's the thing.
I'm not hating on theory.
I was like,
fuck you.
You know,
we're also a successful professional fighter.
You're not just a regular hater.
He just said,
dude,
why am I special?
Kind of
successful former fighter,
fought many different organizations like for you to be rooting on somebody.
It feels different
to me.
It's okay.
I'm glad I got the stamp of approval if he just doesn't feel I get it.
You like the style.
I mean,
who doesn't like knock out?
Who the fuck doesn't like knockouts?
Everybody loves it.
I love him man.
Like Jeremy Stevens.
This is the guy that I love to watch fight,
right?
Like when I was fighting him.
That's a different story.
But like watching him fight.
Yes.
I want to see that every time.
But then when I'm fighting him,
I want you to root for me.
He had a terrifying style.
Still has a terrifying style.
He's just do or die.
If Jeremy connects,
you go over,
you can be Foxville and he carries that power deep deep into a fight.
No,
I remember when he was young and he fought rda.
Yes.
Yeah.
That upper cut and that was a.
That was a highlight reel.
Upper cut for a long time.
Mom fight.
Rda Guzman.
I saw the end of it to the last round.
Who sponsored mother fucker?
Someone's dangerous.
I was,
I was at Bella tour.
I was Abella toyed with,
um,
with Chili and Bomba juicy shillings fight great.
He looked great.
He looks like he looks like a completely different guy.
We were in the dressing room warming up.
He's warming up and he's hitting mitts.
And um,
my first thought was,
yeah,
he looks like he's doing the defensive takedowns sitting low.
It's more comfortable,
like,
yeah,
he's a different dude.
He's very different.
He's putting,
he's got to that point where you,
um,
it's not,
it's not uncomfortable to wrestle like he didn't know what to do for a long time
and I've been gone for a while.
I came back and he was,
he was out there with cowboy and Mickey and,
and,
and Jafar even near.
And those guys really helped him and I'm,
I'm rolling with him and I'm like,
oh,
this is a different character.
You know,
I'm like,
this is not going to be easy.
I better get my,
I bet a tap him now while I can,
you know.
Well,
he's a world class kickboxer,
so in when it comes to the standup game,
he's going to have an advantage over almost everybody as long as he can defend
take downs and as long as he fight smart,
you know,
if he doesn't fight recklessly,
which is,
you know,
we had in the past that a Japanese fellow that knocked him out twice.
Yes.
What's the car's name?
Cocoon.
What's unknown?
That's.
No,
that's not his name.
I'm horrible Japanese names.
They all sound the same because of Beasto.
I got hit so fucking hard that joe his heart.
Joe Does.
It really hits hard.
Saki.
Kado.
Yeah.
That guy is a beast though.
That guy fought in mma and then follow them.
Kickboxing.
I mean that's what it would have been stuck.
It is.
And it's not really a kickboxer as much as he is a fighter,
but joe is.
Joe is turning into an MMA fighter,
so as hip for sure.
So I'm.
So I'm duke everything and on top of secured top position held him and ground
and pound was can
a real strikers,
real strikers have horrific ground because they just congenital it so much more
power from the top.
It's just terrifying,
you know?
Yeah.
Now that he knows how to,
how to control his hips when he's on the ground.
Yeah.
It's just a different story.
I want to see.
Um,
I want to see where he goes and now he's,
he's like,
it's weird because now he's like a prospect in a different way.
Well,
he just needed to fix that one piece of his game and he fixed that one piece of
his game,
the grappling and the take down the fences.
I want to see joe get to the point where he's,
um,
he's completely comfortable on the ground.
He's,
he's,
he's close to it,
but like an two or three years down the road,
him and style bender.
Right?
Stop under anders.
Special kind of dude.
Yeah.
Yes.
Especially kind of do that.
Derek Brunson fight showed it.
It's like this special kind of dude.
I like that kid who diseases.
Yeah.
He's fun to watch,
man.
He's slick.
He's fighting Anderson next.
I don't like that phrase.
Yeah,
I don't like these fights were like I didn't like a year and Bj,
I don't,
I don't like these fights were like these guys who've done so much for the game
are kinda getting fed to the wolves in their,
in their twilight,
but every now and then you get a Shogun Tyson.
Pedro fight the fucking old lion roars again.
Right?
Do you see that fight?
I missed all the UFC fights this weekend because of Bella tour and the boxing
match.
Shogun returned from adversity to.
I heard harden that fight.
He got staggered and fucked up.
Tyson poured it on but couldn't keep it up.
And then shogun got him to the ground,
smashed him up a bit,
got them standing up,
hit him with a big right hand at the end of the fight,
dropped him and then beat the fuck out of them on the ground is like it was.
It was for me.
When I saw that fight announced Tyson.
Pedro was struggles like,
Damn.
Sjogren's got another hard fight.
It's hard watching shogun get knocked out a bunch of times,
but he won and he won a big way and he wanted a war was a war.
He still fuck.
He still a fucking bad ass.
How is shogun still so goddamn aggressive too.
Like he's not slow down.
It was like real frantic and aggressive and it was awesome.
This thing inside you,
right?
You can't get rid of that.
Well,
some dudes,
they lose a bit of it when they take too much punishment there they lose some of
the ferocity or some of the enthusiasm or whatever the fuck it is.
But I was one of the things.
I was watching that fight.
I was like,
God Damn Shogun,
ferocious,
just everything about it.
Like when he got,
had to do to hurt,
he was fucking porn it on,
but it was pointed on in a demonic way,
like a monster.
Like he was like,
he was enjoying it.
Like he was shogun.
Shogun of old man.
Yeah.
This is it.
I mean he fought really well too.
Like his ground game was real solid.
His ground and pound was real solid,
but it was also like his,
his,
the exchanges.
He would be wanting to find openings.
He was frantic and very real aggressive.
Yeah,
it was a.
It was an awesome fight,
man.
Yeah,
I had a fight.
Pass this.
Yeah,
it was an fs.
One thing.
I don't know when.
When did they put those efforts?
One fights on fight pass.
I think it's like a month because that what it is.
I think go,
go further
ahead of this because this is a long period where Tyson was trying to secure
Kamora.
You don't.
You don't go overseas,
right?
Not Anymore.
Now those would cripple me,
man.
Those fucking those overseas things.
There's where you dropped them with the right hand?
Yeah,
they direct me for a week and a half afterwards.
I'd be exhausted.
Fucking Brazil or fly to Australia is worse.
That's what I was going to say.
I was like Brazil.
Isn't that just like north south?
Pretty much.
It is,
but it's still 16 hours on a plane.
Really?
Yeah.
You got to fly to Miami and then you get a flat 10 more hours to Rio.
It's 10 hours from Miami to real.
Yeah.
I didn't realize that.
The South America zone,
that's a whole nother country.
Different continent.
I loved being there.
I hated getting there.
I hated going home.
I hated how I felt afterwards.
And I'm just too busy.
It's just too.
It's too costly for me financially to take that much time off.
And it's also,
it's just too hard for me physically,
you know?
So if they compensated you for the time,
it's dope.
Physically
know fuck you money.
But uh,
I,
you know what the other problem is man,
this fucking TV and watch it on fight.
Pass doing fight companions.
You know those fight companions of the shit
we did.
I did that one with you in jail.
Yeah,
we did more glory.
we got to do another one.
We'll definitely do it for,
for a UFC.
Yes,
yes.
Yeah.
Let's pick one.
You got it.
You know what?
What are you going to be for new years?
I'm going to be on vacation.
Oh,
okay.
Well,
I was going to say,
if you're here,
do a do a fight,
do a fight companion for the.
For PFL.
Yeah.
So tell me about pfl.
So you are,
you're doing commentary for the PFL commentary and telestrator and who else is
doing it with you?
Randy and Randy and Boston.
What a combination.
Right?
What a fucking combination.
When,
when,
when I got that call and they were like,
in the team is going to be you randy in Boston.
Like,
wait,
you just put my name in the same sentence that those dudes is like as equals.
And it's like for me,
like I get,
I get like some fly,
some fight fans may be thinking,
yeah,
that makes sense.
But like for me,
I'm like these guys I looked up to,
you know,
and now I get to,
I get to hang out with them and you know,
we're having a drink at the bar.
That's pretty amazing.
But listen dude,
you're a really good commentator.
You're really good analysts to.
I loved watching the Fox decks desk.
I loved the way you break down things.
You know,
one of the cool things about that desk is you'll have like a Michael bisping or
your half in or you know,
a Kenny Florian,
whoever it is,
everyone's got their own idea of how to fight and what,
what,
what's important and what they think is going to be a problem in a fight.
Like that's such a great move to have these x fighters and continue to,
you know,
10 cormier is always doing it.
Continue to have them explaining from their own experience.
Yeah.
That's,
um,
that was the first thing for.
Because I
didn't,
I was like,
I don't know what I'm doing.
You know,
I have no idea what it is I'm doing,
but it's just talking about fights and it's so much fun to be doing it with,
with guys that are on that same level because you know,
you're at home,
you probably do it when,
when,
when you're at home and you're not doing a fight companion watching fights and
maybe some friends around,
they ask you things about fights and you're like,
you have to explain it to people who don't understand.
But when you're having a conversation with somebody who knows what's going on
and then you can eat,
especially when you come to a point where you disagree because you have strong,
you have strong opinions.
Why?
And you have strong arguments as to why you're right and why the other guy's
wrong.
And I,
I dunno,
I like,
I love those moments man.
I love having those things.
Especially being able to do that with guys who know what they're talking about.
Oh,
it makes it so much more fun when you're doing it with guys who know what
they're talking about.
What's one of the cool things about fight companion is that were set when Brian
counselors talking.
Just kidding,
just kidding Brian.
Just kidding.
But when,
when you're doing it like everybody's got their own opinion of how something
could go down or how,
what,
what's gonna be a problem?
A lot of times you agree,
you know,
like the,
like the till Tyron Woodley fight will tills chances standing up.
That's it.
And you know,
if I was tired I'd take him to the ground.
I mean determines a far better wrestler.
Far,
much,
much more experience,
but like there's some fights were like,
man,
I like,
here's one this weekend,
Brian Ortega,
Max Holloway.
Oh fuck.
Knows how that's going to go.
Like I've,
I've bounced that one around my head and people,
people would come up to me on the street like,
hey man,
who's going to win this fight this weekend?
Especially Hawaiians.
Hawaiians are super excited for Max Holloway to win again.
I mean he's the new Bj Penn.
Right.
And theRe may be a different level.
Max max hallways,
a mother fucker.
That's,
that's one of those fights.
YeAh.
It's very hard to pick a it was that even like,
it's pretty even gotta be.
I mean,
what,
what the vegas odds are.
I,
by the way,
I love the fact that you can actually gamble on fights now online.
Like it's lean,
it's legal.
They kind of do it right.
If you were fighting with myself,
depending on the state to have too much pressure,
I wouldn't want to think about it unless I knew,
unless the guy was a fucking asshole and now I'm going to go smash this.
Like there's just no.
Very close.
They're both minus,
minus one,
minus 1:25,
which would be all the favorite slight favorite.
does that make sense?
Yeah,
that makes sense.
That should be how it is.
Slight favorite because he's the champion and you know it's interesting with
hallway said he goes,
he goes,
it's kind of weird when he goes.
It's kind of weird when the,
the new thing is older than the current thing.
Cause it's like I'm younger man.
I'm the fucking champ.
I beat.
Although I'd been all these dudes,
I'm younger and yet this guy is the new thing coming up and challenge me.
It's like motherfucker,
I'm the younger fighter.
It's kind of funny.
Well yeah,
I mean we haven't seen,
we haven't seen something like or tag a little bit in um,
in the featherweight division guy submitting like only submissions off to like
the one with cub.
Yeah.
I think that was beautiful.
Like he readjusted on that teaM too.
That's,
that's probably the hardest submission to readjust,
you know,
one hand hanging on readjusting and then still sinking it in against cubs won.
It's not like it's not like Brandon Bishop or whoever it's comes once.
You know what I mean?
That's like,
that's crazy man.
Well,
he's a direct lineage,
right?
He's real gracie jujitsu.
He is henner and he Iran,
you know he's come.
He comes from horry on that school.
I mean this is where brian comes from.
He's direct from those mats and his technique is like razor blades so sharp.
It's so sharp and precise and so honed and just through drills and a constant
emphasis on proper leverage and position.
I mean there are sticklers to that old style of jujitsu and some people.
There's an unfortunate word that people like to use that sometimes pisses people
off.
Like vinny magalhaes use this to describe minataro and he didn't mean it in a
negative way,
but he meant the basics.
He's like his jujitsu is very basic.
He'd ended up people go fucking my jujitsu is basic,
but the basic is like the best,
the fundamentals,
but these guys that have those basics like hotter gracie,
his jujitsu is.
He's mostly the basics.
He's not doing any crazy della hiva shit or anything that you've never seen
before.
Like,
yeah,
he's not doing anything.
We never saw it before.
It's strict,
you know,
guard,
pass,
smashing on top,
triangle,
mount arm,
triangle armbar.
Everything he does is classic jujitsu,
but it's just so perfect.
Everything,
the leverage and the weight and the emphasis on,
you know,
certain positions over others.
It's all like basic classic jujitsu and that's Brian Ortega.
His jujitsu is just so rock solid fundamentals.
You know,
he's all about fundamentals,
man.
Even his box,
he's not,
I don't believe he's as good a boxer as as Max,
but he's fundamentally sound strong and direct with his boxing mean.
He knocked out frankie,
he knocked out frankie.
He submitted my condo who I think is one of the dark horse in that division and
auto marcano is a fucking beast.
Man.
Mike brown has nothing but praise for him,
man.
He's like,
that kid is legit.
He's,
he's going to challenge for that title.
I believe that.
I believe that and he's super respectful and intelligent and like everything
about him I like.
I love his,
his approach,
the way he fights and in that fight,
hollowell or excuse me,
ortega made him shoot because he was beating him standing up and he shot and
ortega.
I think you
that good team.
It's just a death grip.
He's just got a vice.
Just clamps down on your fucking life,
put you to sleep.
There's no room,
there's no room.
You're going To sleep or you're going to tap.
You need a kid.
he's my size.
He's big.
He's
a big.
He's big.
Macs is big to their max is huge.
Max was 185.
When they told him about the fight,
the horrible thing about that fight was that he lost all that weight really
rapidly for no reason and then they wound up pulling him out of the fight,
know the commissioners like fuck this.
You can't fight.
And a lot of us at the time were like,
why is the commission telling the champion whether or not he could make,
wait,
let him try to make weight.
Get the fuck out of there.
You don't know what you're doing,
but then you find out after that that like when he was preparing for the first
fight with ortega and he was experiencing these weird concussion like symptoms
symptoms,
but they said he didn't have a concussion and then people will say,
no,
this is weight loss,
this is rapid weight cuttings.
Body is responding to the fact that you just went through this and now I was
trying to do it again and his body's rejecting it.
So this is a bunch of theories.
There's not.
They're not giving us a whole lot of information about exactly what's wrong with
him medically or what was wrong.
Whether theY know it or not,
I don't know.
Right.
But even or take has been saying all week like what the fuck was wrong with him?
Why not?
How come they're not telling us like what if it happens again or take has got to
be thinking right now.
Here we are today.
It's wednesday,
tomorrow's thursday.
The weigh ins friday.
He'll only got a couple of days like we don't know whether or not this is even
actually going to happen.
right?
Like what if it gets down to thursday and friday and he's in the middle of the
weight cut and he starts blacking out or he starts experiencing those symptoms
again.
They pull them out of the car more ikonos on standby,
you know,
I did not know that he's on standby for this fight that he see and then it
becomes an interim title.
It must,
it has to be.
They're not going to strip them,
but then what happens?
I mean a guy like max that I don't know.
It's,
it's one of those situations where it's like,
if that happens multiple times,
like what do you have to do?
Kim,
can you continue to,
how much longer can you continue to fight at that weight?
I don't think he can continue to fight it that way very much longer because I
think he severely compromises himself getting done in 45.
But he's been able to do it because he's a champion.
But.
And I think if you do have a,
a like a george lockhart in your corner,
a guy that gets you to do it scientifically and they rehydrate yourself
scientifically,
it can be done and you can pull it off in 24 hours later.
You can fight at a very high level.
But is that the way to go?
I mean,
the kidneys start breaking down,
your body starts getting beat up and your organs don't want to get dried out
like that.
Your brain doesn't want to get dried out like that.
Your muscles don't want to get dried out like that.
There's just no way you perform at your best when you're just at death's door 24
hours ago.
And now here you're fighting again.
Yeah,
I mean,
frankie,
you know,
when he was fighting at lightweight,
that kinda kinda shows you that you can be the smaller guy and do well.
But it's weird because like now frankie said a bar and now guys reached that bar
so he had to change weight classes.
You know,
that's,
it's a weird thing.
And everybody's gonna.
I mean,
it's the fight game.
You always,
you try to get the best out of yourself and you try to get the biggest advantage
that you can,
so the weight cut's gonna always be an issue.
Unless the way classes are changed and or weIgh ins become same day.
Well josh thompson just said recently that he thinks that the ufc is getting rid
of the 125 pound division.
They're got to put on a one 65 pound division,
which I think is very interesting.
If they do do a one 65,
I would like them to switch one 72 [inaudible] 75.
I think that would be wise.
I don't think it's wise to have a 65 and 75,
but I do think of 65 and 75 is great,
right?
Yeah,
I agree.
I 10 pounds 10 pounds is good.
I think across the board,
I think we had every 10 pounds of weight class.
I mean a lot of people don't like the boxing thing.
There's so many champions and so many weight classes,
but who fucking cares?
Who cares?
Who cares that there's a welterweight and then a super welterweight really cares
that it's only seVen pounds difference.
This is more fights.
It's more fights,
more champions.
It's more champion versus champion.
I mean,
don't you want to see that?
I want to see that.
I want is.
Yeah.
I want to see the best in the best.
You know what I mean?
We're,
we're getting,
we're getting some of the best of the best right now.
You get the number.
Let's say Kevin Lee.
Kevin lee could be 165 pound champion.
Yes.
But.
And probably that's his weight class struggles to make 1:55.
He's a bIg fella.
He's a big dude but then can't do it anymore.
But like tyron wrestled at one 65.
Imagine if he was still that age,
you know,
and he could fight at one 65.
Get tyron can make 65.
I've been tiring.
Can make 65.
I think he can make 65.
I definitely think he could fight at 75 and be at his best.
And I think he could also fight at 85.
I think tyron has legitimate potential to be a three division champion.
He should start.
You should start rallying for that.
For that 65 pound weight class.
Nobody listens to me anymore.
If they listened to me,
melvIn manhoef would've been in the ufc back in 2002.
They listen to me sometimes.
I think they listen to me with ben aspirin on record and I'm gonna say I'm a big
reason why I've been asking and gotten the ufc.
I brokered a meeting between him and dana white.
Okay,
dude.
I put it together.
I called dana.
I said,
look,
he's a good guy,
man.
He's talking shit.
But everybody talks shit like,
come on.
I'm like,
the guys undefeated.
And he's like,
uh.
He was like,
when ambien wants to go to sleep,
it takes ben aspirin
and I'm like fighting.
See,
the thing about fighting is it's not a matter of what is the,
what's exciting to watch for a person like you,
a person like me who's like sitting by the.
How is this going to play out?
What's gonna work?
What works?
I get that.
Yeah.
I want to see what works when when I see a guy like ben asked her and I want to
see what works well,
he's a three to one favorite over robbie lawler.
Holy shit.
That's crazy.
Just added another fight to this card.
Listen man,
you can't sleep on robbie fucking law.
Don't sleep on robbie lawler.
That's crazy.
Three to 1:30.
One is horror glued.
Robbie lawler can bressler.
Robin has been shutting people's lights out since the early two.
Thousands.
Decent bet then.
So fucking good.
I would take,
I'd take the robbie lawler six actually being three to 100 to make $300 plus
2:30.
Two 33 to one.
So you'd have to win the bet three to win one on aspirin,
right?
Correct.
Yeah.
Yeah,
I'd take that bad.
It's a good bet,
but I,
I'd like aspirin's chances because I think that wrestling is just on another
level.
Yeah,
that's the fight.
Here's the fight.
One 65 khabib.
Ben aspirin.
I guess bank could make 6,500 percent.
He can make 6,500 percent.
One hundred percent.
He wants to make 65 because he's good friends with tyron and he's like,
I'll be the 65 pound champ tire and be the 70 or 75,
whatever.
They decided to go with that.
That's the fight khabib versus ben asked me,
because I'm teLling you man,
ben aspirin,
they just put his face on the camera the other day while he was in the crowd and
the audience went crazy.
This isn't even fought in the ufc and they love him.
Yeah.
Fight real has as that.
Didn't know who he is.
Now they know who he is now.
It's like he's been building momentum.
The hardcore fans.
Absolutely.
You're excited that finally this undefeated fee nom of a wrestler is fighting in
the ufc?
Yeah,
I would.
Yeah.
I would pay money to watch him fucked.
Yeah,
for sure.
A lot of money.
I'll fly to Russia for that fight.
You think that's where they have it?
Fuck,
I don't know,
man.
I'm about to fly to Russia and commentate that fight.
Yeah,
and I'm going to,
as soon as I get to my hotel room,
I'm going to have one of them.
Things,
it checks for bugs.
Did you check for hidden cameras and
he cut
it up like a christmas tree?
Yeah,
it will.
Probably would write the whole house is a fucking bug that.
Yeah,
man,
I think that's a.
That's,
that's a fight that I'm very,
very excited about because like right now,
khabib,
the number one fight for khabib I believe is tony ferguson.
I think that's a big fight.
A giant fight.
I'm real excited about that.
I like that.
I heard,
I heard rumors and I was spoken to dustin of that whole tony and khabib,
dustin and conor fight each other.
I heard that too,
but here's the cynical part of me.
I know that nate diaz was supposed to be fighting dustin,
but dustin had a pull out with a hip injury,
so I'm like,
okay,
well how bad is his hip injury and when is that going to heal up,
you know,
and isn't going to heal up,
or is it going to be a reoccurring thing?
And them saying that dustin is going to step in and he's going to fight conor.
That is a good fight.
But does that make nate diaz go?
what does that make nate?
Nate diaz come back to the bargaining table and then they have like.
Because that's the big money fight.
Big money.
If I was a promoter,
I'm not a promoter.
I'd be like,
nate,
what are we going to do?
Got to get weed.
We got to get girls to.
Do you want a new bike?
Put the fuck.
What are we going to do with lists of weeding girl delivered.
We'd
like for real.
Like if you wanted to make money and that's what I presumed they all want to do.
And the reason why they want to have brock lesnar fight dc is because they want
to make a shit ton of money,
right?
Yeah.
Nate.
Mother fucking des.
You want to make money?
You call nate mother fucking ds.
Go party with them.
Become a good friend.
Lightened him up.
give him what he wants.
Give them a lot of money.
that's a good fight.
We saw it twice.
You know,
it's not just a good fight.
It's a gigantic like fan friendly spectacle of inexperience.
Nate diaz doesn't take any bullshit.
You can't trash talk him.
It doesn't work.
Yeah,
exactly.
It doesn't work.
It works the opposite way.
Works the opposite way.
Like when connor shit talk,
nate.
Nate was like,
fuck you.
I was like,
what?
Like it didn't work.
I ain't gonna lie man.
One of my favorite.
Nate fights with him and him and cowboy.
Oh,
that was great fight.
He got in cowboys head.
He did.
There was a good lesson for cowboy though.
So important fight for them in terms of like the path of his career.
Yeah.
He grew something from that.
Yeah,
but that,
that third round,
nate standing there,
flipping the bird.
How good the cowboy looking against Mike Perry.
holy shit.
It's a new cowboy.
He looked different.
Man.
Look different.
Just everything looks smooth and just like a goddamn execution.
I heard rumors of that too.
I heard rumors,
a cowboy and connor.
That's a fight that I would make.
I would make that fight.
That's,
that's,
that's how fucking exciting fight.
And that's what also a big sell.
You could sell the shit out of that fight.
That's a big fight.
But,
but connor,
excuse me,
cowboys not been fighting at 55,
you know,
it's been doing majority of his fights.
Um,
that's another 165.
Yeah.
How many fights do you fought til he's fought mosfet.
All those are all seventies.
You know,
they're all 75.
perry
was in another one.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
The John Edwards.
Yeah.
so that's um,
those are all seventies.
Yeah.
I don't think he's fought 55 in quite a while now.
You can still make it though.
It's not a big 70.
Yeah.
I think he was talking about going back to 55.
Say something and you know,
and If they do have a 65 pound weight class and he can
see it,
I just,
there's a lot of great fights at 65.
And kevin,
the dude,
anybody in Kevin Lee,
kevin leaves a beast.
Man,
he's something special.
I think kevin was one of those dudes.
You don't see him fight for six months and then he gets in there and you got a
whole different animal in front of you.
You've got to go with new skills,
new momentum,
new experiences.
Just he gets,
he's just in that,
I think he's 25 right now.
He's in that peak prime learning,
growing confidence
part of his career where he's just,
he's just a monster right now.
I don't know,
man.
Those,
those guys are so much bigger than than the guy.
So my day.
I know that 55.
Yeah,
kevin's like walks around 190 pounds.
Big guy and I'm retired.
I'm retired.
I'm no longer in this.
I don't worry about my weight as much and I stand next to these guys and they're
still bigger than me.
It's like,
how is that?
Why Is that we know.
What's the craziest dc?
Yeah.
He's standing next to the dcs for like five,
10,
five,
10.
And he like,
he could be a middleweight.
It could be a middleweight picks up heavyweights,
tosses them around slams dudes,
you know,
I mean when you see him with derek lewis,
you like terek has no business being in there with the student.
Derek is a legit to 65 murderer,
knockout puncher from hell and no business being there with dc.
Nope.
But then you saw that guy,
um,
when dcs trading partner at the,
at the affliction affliction at the,
um,
tito chuck fight.
Oh,
tom lawler.
I didn't see that fight.
Oh yeah.
He's like five.
six.
Really?
Yeah.
Five,
six,
two.
Oh five.
What is your 85 or two?
Oh,
five.
Really?
Five.
Six.
Who is he?
Um,
I forget his first name.
When is his last name?
He fought tom lawler.
He dc dc is like,
yeah,
this guy takes me down.
Um,
yeah,
he's a good wrestler.
But It's funny because he's sprawled on tom lawler,
but he's on his feet.
He's standing,
but he's taught a lot is on his knees,
like on his knees upright.
Wow.
This kid is sprawl I guess.
Yeah,
I guess I'm older than him.
Just get sprawled on his head.
Yeah.
But he,
he can,
he can box to when he's literally.
It looks a little awkward.
He looks like a guy and you're in a walmart parking lot.
You'd talk shit to him because he's little fuck you up.
Do you remember dwight mohammed car?
We know he used to be.
Dwight braxton.
He was the Light heavyweight champion way back in the day,
and then he fought evander holyfield as a cruiserweight and a car.
We was one 95.
He was five slash seven.
He was just a tank of a man and he would come at you like this,
just real low.
He would get even lower and he was a tough,
tough guy,
man.
And real thick.
Like you didn't see many dudes that were that thick back then and he would wear
his trunks way up high.
So you have like this much body to hit and it was all just jack.
It's like the strike zone.
Yeah.
He's going to get a smaller.
Who's one of the first big tests for eVander holyfield?
Yeah.
Dwight muhammad car wheat from camden,
New Jersey,
camden,
buzzsaw.
That feels like.
I feel like that.
I've heard of that,
but I don't remember anything.
I feel like even holyfield versus kawaii.
Kawaii.
You spelled with a q.
You Talk about.
You talk about that way way I think.
How do you spell call?
We said qa,
qa,
wi.
yeah.
I found the other guy.
Darren,
when you have a cute note,
you different language.
Yeah.
What is that to aws role?
Q always has a.
You write in english?
Yeah.
Doesn't it?
Let me see what it is that you start with a q cv.
Get into that.
Yeah.
See,
this is.
He would fight real low.
It was just a tank of a dude.
Yeah.
And he was like all like bobbing and weaving and always ducking under punches.
And this is a vendor holyfield fresh out of the olympics.
He had had a few uh,
boxing matches but wasn't.
Know wasn't.
It wasn't the evander holyfield that we think of when he won the heavyweight
title.
And this is also before he started training with mackie shall stone and mackey
shields don't put a lot of muscle on them.
Being them a lot bigger.
He was 195 pounds back then.
It was like see much thinner is.
Let's see,
like this is the style of that.
Bob and weave instyle,
ceo of anders having a hard time hitting him,
but he,
you move your head,
protect your body when you're that small and he was giving you all forehead and
it was a big old ball for him too,
so it was just like,
he's like coming at you all for head first.
Just a real skillful old school boxer though in stem socks,
old school stripes,
stripes on the calf,
pulled
all the way up.
I still love watching these old boxing matches.
This is something that really mismanaged that.
Boxing used to be on tv,
wide world of sports,
you know,
show shown.
Actually aloma chenko like the best aloma chanko to last than espn to like it.
Well,
he fights on espn is doing some serious world championship fights.
Espn has really stepped up in,
especially now that hbo has gotten out of the game.
It's.
I mean it's in a precarious situation.
I don't know why hbo decided to get out of the boxing game.
It's kind of crazy to me,
but after all those years of covering the greatest fights ever,
hbo decided to just pull out.
I know that when the guy that started that or not started it,
but that guy who's like the pay per view model creator,
mark taffet and he,
he left and I don't know if,
if that had something to do with it,
I'd imagine it has to be a profitability thing.
I think that's the only thing that makes sense.
Yeah.
It has to be that they just,
what they were losing money.
I mean,
you gotta think the production is huge,
right?
You got all these cameras and all those thing and they're,
they're alive.
They got to get the trucks that production trucks.
It's probably a live sports is probably an extremely expensive thing to pull
off,
you know?
Yeah,
yeah.
It makes sense.
But they were the best at it.
Lampley and kellerman.
I mean fucking commentary.
Roy jones jr doing commentary with them sometimes.
Andre ward,
you know,
they had some of the best fights ever.
The best team ever.
I agree.
Jones jr.
I loved Roy Jones,
jr.
tried to get him in here to shit,
you know,
[inaudible].
Do you know what,
what's happening with him that uh,
michael b dot talking about?
he could
box Roy Jones.
I love your reaction.
Yes.
That's funny.
I love,
I love a cocky,
like robust young
man who's delusional.
Yeah.
You got to add that caveat.
I mean,
he's a fucking beast if you look at his body,
right?
Right.
Michael Jordan is just jacked full six pack bill.
Like a greek goD.
But son stop.
It creates a movie.
It's a movie man.
I know.
You felt good hitting those pads.
No,
you look good.
Look at him.
Roy jones jr will light you up like a christmas tree in times square.
This rodman in this quarter.
I don't think that's dennis rodman.
I think it's his brother.
I mean he's jacked for sure.
It looks good,
but listen to terrible disaster.
Check out my segway.
Like if he thinks he's tough,
he can fight in pfl for me.
And ah.
So what is the deal with pfl in the million dollar thing?
Like what is it for each individual weight class on,
on new Year's eve,
there's a,
there's a $10,000,000 prize pool.
All the winners,
six winners of their championship fights get a million dollars.
So three fights for me.
Million dollars because it's playoffs.
Fights,
right?
The playoffs are cool too though because once you make the off,
if you lose in the quarters,
it's a guaranteed 50.
You lose in the semis.
That's 100.
And then the finals are,
the winner gets a million.
The loser.
200 still good.
Still good money,
right?
I'm,
I'm happy to see how good vinnie's doing.
Vinny meghalaya beast.
he's a completely different guy.
You know,
he always had the,
the,
some of the best jujitsu you're ever going to see an mma peter.
Yeah.
But then hiS striking wasn't up to par,
but now it is.
His striking was good.
I mean he won two fights because of his striking one with strikes and one by
setting it up with his striking.
You know,
vinny,
he's,
he's really working out and he says,
he says he claims to be training four times a day for this.
Um,
and he,
he looked that way,
he didn't get out of the first round,
like each fight got longer and the longest flight with like two minutes,
33 seconds or something like that.
His jujitsu.
Who's on another level?
Vinny magallanes is one to just forget about mma.
He's one of the best in his weight class on the planet earth in jujitsu.
I mean he's a monster.
Do you ever see when a flying arm barred paid upon?
No.
No dude.
Dude,
when you,
you're flying armbar a world champion like paid upon?
No,
I mean vinny just they tie up and vinny just throws his 220 pound body up in the
air and snatches his arm out of nowhere.
Flip flips them over on his back and paid upon,
tapped out.
And he was like,
if it needs a ninja,
he's a bad motherfucker.
Motherfucker on.
That's um,
I think that that is the fight that I'm the second flight that I'm looking to
the most for the,
for the,
for the finals.
Then that ray cooper,
the third dude,
he's another one.
Five slash seven.
Yeah.
Hay makers vicious.
Why did they make jake shields fight that dude again,
this just how it played out.
That's crazy.
The number eight seed right?
Smashed by by ray and then he's got to fight him again.
Yeah,
and it's like he didn't have much time in between the five months,
not even five months.
Formula was like,
let me see.
The first one happened in like july.
The second was october,
july,
august,
september three months.
Yeah.
How crazy is it that jake fought his dad?
Jake ford is that 14 years ago and then when they were scheduled to fight the
first time.
Jake his favorite,
because we know who jake jake shields is.
We don't know who ray cooper.
The third is we don't know state champion wrestler hay makers hits like a truck
and he's just a tank of a man and when you see him in there,
he doesn't look as small as like when I stand next to them and talk to him,
it's like he's a short,
stocky guy,
but then when he's in there against jake shields,
he.
I don't know.
That persona,
that attitude,
that personality.
He's coming forward and jake's backing up and it makes him look bigger than he
is.
well,
he's only five slash seven,
but jesus fucking christ,
he hit so hard.
He's terrifying to any.
He's crispr technique like it's not just like throwing wide looping fucking
ridiculous punches like ricardo,
my org or some shit that they hit you.
You're fucked.
No,
he's throwing everything with great technique.
He's a monster.
I,
I mean he's,
he's,
he's been my biggest favorite this,
this season.
Like just watching.
Well he's unquestionably world class and so it was vinny and that's one of the
more interesting things about today's climate.
I feel like with bella tour with a pfl for absolutely with one fc.
You have world class fighters in many organizations.
It's not just the ufc and these guys can all come over and compete and
essentially at the top of the heap right now and basically you've got lance
palmer,
these guys in almost every organization that I feel like I can compete with the
best in the world in any organization.
It's,
it's getting pretty even now,
much more so than it was four or five years ago.
Yeah,
it's weird though because all of these things happened in the past.
We had prIde,
we had strived for us,
you know,
the wec and then those things got absorbed,
right.
And then all the best guys ended up in the ufc and it's like,
well all the best guys are here now.
And like now these other organizations,
one was still around in one was always not a threat but always,
always had quality quality fighters,
you know,
now we know that the one,
there's some really the guys over at one.
Then we got asked him coming over now,
the pfl starting now,
like guys like vinny is his career.
Like he's a different guy now.
Like with the fight,
he can compete with anybody at two.
Oh five.
Exactly.
Like it's a very different story for a lot of guys,
but now what happens when,
when these guys in the ufc,
the number eighth rank heavyweight in the ufc sees a guy make a million dollars.
I would.
And he's.
And he's thinking,
fuck that guy up.
I love it.
It's good.
It's good for everybody.
Yeah,
competition is great for the sport.
It's great for the athletes,
it's great for the organizations because the organizations,
whether they like it or not,
it's gonna.
Make them pick up their game,
going to make them step up.
Some people don't like to pick up the game,
joe.
Some people like to because they just like to be comfortable that it's not live.
It's not.
That is not lying.
It's not piCk up your game.
Then I got.
I got.
I.
There was something I wanted to show you that I'm bed reminded me of why I need
to pick up my game.
I was looking through my phone a couple months ago and I have this video of my
dad.
I'm going to show it to you to turn this down,
but I'm just going to go straight to the end because that's the coolest part.
Do you want to send it to jamie?
Yeah,
I can do that.
Can you airdrop it to him?
I can airdrop.
I love technology for the mac.
I see young jamie's mbp.
That's it.
Bam.
Here we go.
Jamie,
what are you going to call yourself when you hit 50 little wing going to call
themselves?
The best answer ever,
I didn't name myself named you.
That's true.
Good point.
But you got to go through,
you've got to go forward some through some of it,
but yeah,
like,
lIke,
just reminded of like some of the things in my life I would,
I've been kind of.
What are we going to say?
What is this?
So my dad,
my dad,
das limbo,
right.
My dad was the baddest limbo dance on the planet really?
um,
and he did some crazy,
crazy stuff.
You might need to try it again.
It didn't.
Oh,
probably when I close my phone.
Okay.
Um,
there we go.
Waiting for jamie to grab it and I'll leave it open.
I'm no,
my dad used to dance in limbo and I'm limos when you go onto the stick.
Yes.
And um,
he,
I don't want to,
I don't want to ruin it.
Right.
But he was the best jokes from like 88,
like the year before he died.
Wow.
Yeah.
So like I,
I don't know,
uh,
it just reminds me of some of the thing and my family.
Anytime I did something that I thought was cool,
they would just be like,
yeah,
like,
so wait your dad,
your dad would do that kind of like fuck.
Like I could never get out of his shadow,
but this is your dad.
That's my dad.
Oh shit.
Fire.
Yeah.
Damn.
How the fuck is he doing that?
That is insane,
dude.
That's insane.
Yeah.
He did this for like tons of.
Or you did it from a geeves.
Everybody wanted to see him do this.
He did it in front of mandela.
Did it in front of the queen.
Don't know if he's going to go under it there.
Yeah,
but it gets better than this whole lot.
Do you eat?
How the fuck is he doing that?
You don't kind of core strength.
That takes blown far.
But this right here now this is where it gets ridiculous.
This is like,
I see this and I'm like,
yeah,
that's my dad.
Like
he's going to go what?
So this is on fire folks in this.
This thing is I'm not bullshitting.
And he's got to flame and pizzas in his hand
and he's like that.
That mIght be what,
13,
14 inches off the ground and he's going under it.
ThAt's insane.
Any spitting fire while he's doing it?
holy shit.
You weren't joking.
No,
my dad was a bad ass.
That's crazy.
How crazy Is it?
Looking at this old vhs footage digitized?
It's not that long ago,
man.
No,
and that's a different world that,
that,
that kind of thing.
My dad kind of,
I mean I was always with.
I used to love being with him,
you know,
he's like my best friend.
I remember I was telling my son this story about him,
so I had this,
this thing with my kid and I'm recording this conversation with me and my son
and I'm like,
what would you do if you could go back in time?
And he's like,
what?
I was like,
if you had a time machine you can go anywhere.
Where would you go?
He's like,
I don't know,
the 19 hundreds.
And I'm like,
I grew up in the 1900.
What are you talking about?
Like last week
and then I told him this story.
I was like,
yo mama.
I was little.
My dad used to,
I used to bring me on stage to do that.
I was like four or five years old.
No,
I was like four years old.
I,
he would pick me up and carried me under the,
under the bar.
Right.
And one time he raised me on stage.
He's like,
this is my son,
and he presents me,
the spotlight's on me and I'm like shy.
And I'm like,
oh.
And he just kind of disappointed,
you know,
he's really disappointed in me that day.
And then,
um,
a couple of weeks later I was with him again.
He's like,
I was like,
daddy,
can we bring back on stage?
And he brings me on stage and um,
he's about to pick me up and I'm like,
walk away.
And I go back to my seat.
And he loved it.
He loved it,
you know,
and I told my son that story.
My dad was like,
he people afterwards,
we walked through the hotel to go back and he has me on his shoulders and he's
just so proud.
He's like,
you see bible and he's like,
you know,
I told my son about that.
My son was like,
it was like 40 minutes later in the conversation and my son is like that.
If I had a time machine I'd go back and hang out with you and your dad.
That was like,
that was the best moment of my life.
Yeah.
Because he didn't get to meet him.
But It's one of those things,
man.
And just,
just thinking about that kind of thing I'm kinda makes it inspires me to,
like,
to,
like want to do things where,
where you know,
kids,
like this is what my dad did that for me.
And he made me excited about things and now I want to do stuff where something
where I can give something to kids.
And um,
just what you're doing with your book.
That's what I'm doing with that.
And,
and like my thing is mixed martial arts,
right?
So this thing,
this is the first book,
the talent quest and um,
so it's about these characters,
these,
you write all this.
So here's the thing,
the concept and the characters camera with me,
I have,
I have a good friend,
she's a,
she's a psychologist,
she's in Australia,
she wrote this story out and then we have this girl that does the illustration,
she's mariam,
she fights,
she fights with one,
she's fighting this weekend,
right?
So like it's all,
It's all about mixed martial arts and the psychology of and working
on all these different things.
But we're going to put this whole program together that that's all about
teaching kids like discipline,
self respect,
self resilience,
all of these things and put these stories together with these characters and
it's a whole lot of fun.
I,
I have a book for you and I want,
I want you to,
to,
to enjoy it with,
with,
you know,
with your little ones.
I will do that.
Thank you man.
That's awesome.
So is this available for sale?
Where can people get it?
So you can get it on amazon and amazon katen was a ktp.
I have have to read the thing in my phone but it's um,
it will be available.
We were going to release it on the 15th of December and um,
you can get it by ebook and you can also get it.
I'm a printed copy like this,
so let me know when it comes out.
It's the 15th of December,
15th of December.
Remind me and I'll tweet it,
man.
That'd be so dope.
um,
when this pfl thing comes out,
when,
when is this on new year's?
And it's on nbc.
Nbc sports.
So What channel was that on?
What does nbc sports on?
Direct tv.
That's one of the weird ones.
You got to find it.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
You want to watch the olympics,
right?
Is that what it's on?
Nbc sports.
And you want to watch curling?
Synchronize taekwondo shit.
Yeah.
Talking about.
Know say they're going to do mma.
They're talking about doing mma and the olympics.
Yeah,
I heard about that.
It's right next to like fs.
One fs,
one to two.
Nineteen mbcs.
Sn is 2:20.
So not great in that channel.
what is nbc?
Is plans for this,
for this?
Is this like,
this is obviously they're spending a lot of money because they're given a
million dollar prize to three different guys.
You know,
one of the pfl is its own organization now,
so it's a,
it's a partnership with nbc,
so the pfl puts the money up for the fighters and nbc does have,
does it,
you know,
there's an influx of money coming in from nbc,
but the pfl is in control of all of that.
So I don't know it nbc plans are,
you know,
but the pfl has big plans.
They have a contract with nbc that I believe the contract is up this year,
but of course they're going to renegotiate,
you know,
they're going to work things out and this is the only product that nbc has.
Mma is hot right now.
So I don't believe nbc wants to,
wants to let the pfo go.
It's the thing that seems to be the bottleneck it with other organizations is
the name.
So you know,
the ufc is like the nfl,
right?
So I got this.
It's the biggest name.
Ufc has ever made it to a lot of people to a lot of people.
And then you hear about the pfl what's,
what's that mean?
What's bella tour mean?
Whereas one fc,
what does that mean?
it doesn't mean anything.
You're just like,
it's hard to get.
I think bella tours making some ground,
you know,
because they've been doing plenty of television events and paramount network is
a big network.
a lot of people get the chance to see it.
they've had good ratings,
but it still hasn't caught fire.
Right.
The thing with the pfl yeah,
the name professional fighters league like you hear pfl,
you don't know what that means.
You have professional fighters,
lee,
you have an idea what's going on,
but um,
it's good name,
it's a great name and it's the name
is,
is representative of what it is.
You know,
it's a league.
We have a regular season.
So you fight in the regular season,
you score a certain amount of points,
you score points by getting finishes,
you score points.
We're getting finished in the first,
uh,
you know,
you win the fight.
That's three points you get to finishing the first.
That's three additional points,
second round,
two points,
third now one point.
And then at the end of the regular season,
the top aide seeds get into the playoffs and you fight by your seed.
So that's why jake had the fyc fight.
Ray cooper again is jake kind of edged into that eight spot and ray cooper was
the number one
might want to rework that
to the finished in the third round is worth less than the finished in the first.
So don't make any sense to me.
Yeah.
It's um,
because it's a little tougher to finishing the third.
Not only that,
it's a finish finishes a finish.
Yeah,
I,
I agree,
but I don't
like sometimes it takes a while to finish a guy.
Like,
look,
here's a perfect example.
Say you're fighting a guy like josh thompson,
you know,
back in the day like this is a tough fight.
These are two world class fighters versus you fighting Henry Smith from fucking
albuquerque that nobody knows.
It's different if you finished that guy in the first round like,
yeah,
you've got to finish in the first round,
but did you get to finish over a world class guy?
If you've get a finish of a world class guy in the third,
that's worth more.
I mean it's depending upon who you're fighting and what style they are,
how resilient they are,
how difficult they are to beat,
but then it gets,
becomes more subjective when you're talking about the difficulty and matching up
styles and then you started to bring the odds into it from like,
I guess it wouldn't be betting odds but similar to betting on.
yeah,
so it's one of those things where there is no perfect way but you take what you
have and do the best you can.
I get it,
but a point the differences in two points,
like you get three points for the first round,
but one point if the third phone call that finishes a finnish man,
you,
you.
So bonus points for finishes.
What is a finnish I,
I made that argument.
We had that conversation is like,
but then again,
then what do you do?
How do you get bullied?
What do you get?
Bonus points for
his perfect example.
How dare you,
how dare you try to diminish [inaudible] rodriguez last second,
teo of the korean zombie and noticeable.
He shouldn't get all the points for that.
That was crazy.
He literally knocked the guy out with one second to go with a no look elbow
pack.
I mean that's all the points.
Give them all the points.
That's the git like.
Yeah.
You get,
you get so many points for finish.
Whether it be first,
second or third round finishes.
I agree.
Um,
because the,
the one,
the one difference that we have is,
isn't a draw like both guYs get one point.
I feel that if,
if you or if it goes to a decision,
maybe you should get points,
you know,
maybe we should get a point for surviving,
but the winner gets more and then if you get finished you get no points.
But the finisher gets all the points.
Well it's,
it's definitelY squirrely.
The idea behind it.
SquIrrelly.
I get what they're doing,
but I don't buy it.
I,
I buy the,
I buy the fact that you got to get points because it's kinda like,
I'm kinda like college wrestling,
you know,
you get 10 points,
you get points for a pin,
you get four for the pin,
you get three.
I'm sorry,
you get five for the pen,
you get,
you get six with I'm so you get five for the major decision,
you know,
you get three for the decision.
It's,
it's weird.
But,
and then maybe tweak next year.
There may be some tweaks for people to remember all that shit.
That's the thing.
So we're constantly talking about it on,
on here,
you know,
as,
as the fights going on and people will listen to her drunk though,
like what the fuck,
what is the point that can't do the math?
And once there was no,
but it's,
it's,
it's super cool because it changes sometimes guys' attitudes when they're in
there,
they changes what they do and how they respond in the fight.
You know,
say the fight there was a fight with kyLe allen carr and mike kyle,
right?
Both of these guys needed to finish to get into the playoffs.
Either one of those guys get to finish.
They get into the playoffs.
Josh copeland sitting at home hoping that nobody gets a finished.
The fight starts and boom,
my cow rocks weiland car and it's like it looks like he's going to get a first
round finish,
make it into the playoffs.
Kyle and guard starts coming back.
He gets on top and the second round he looks like he's going to get the finish
and make it to the playoffs.
These guys go to the third.
Both guys a gas now.
Nobody finishes.
josh copeland jumps off his chair at home and he's in the playoffs now and now
he's in the finals.
Like he was the ac.
He beat the number one seed and then he beat the number five seat by kale.
Now he's in the.
He's in the finals and he has a chance to make a million dollars number.
Ac is going in.
InTeresting.
Okay.
That you just made a good argument for it.
I'm not sure if I bought it though.
You buy it,
joe,
you buy it.
Why don't they revamped the scoring system?
I would not be surprised if this off season we do some,
some,
some brainstorming and,
and change a few things,
but I don't know if a whole lot is going to be changed.
Um,
I think a few things will be changed in next.
Season's going to be even better.
And to a man,
I've heard,
I've heard virtually every high level guy,
every ufc level guy that I've spoken to,
they've said to me,
I think going to be able to pay that million dollars when they see that million
dollars is real.
Then I want to see the reaction to that.
That's gonna change everything.
Once people get that million dollar check,
once you see someone you know,
you see vinny magallanes driving around in a ferrari or a rolls royce.
What the fuck?
Look at that motherfucker.
I kicked his ass and a rolls royce.
I know.
Yeah,
you can ask ryan bader sitting around going,
what the fuck?
Excuse me.
Matt.
Ryan betas.
Another guy who's transformed,
right?
Yeah.
He's like a legit heavyweight contender.
Now he looks fucking good,
man.
The way beat mitrione jesus christ.
And mitch elon has improved.
She owns improved a lot,
knocked out,
fade door.
I mean,
come on,
that's a,
I mean,
that's a feather in your cap for the rest of your life.
Shoot.
I sat next to fatal and that's a feather in my cap.
I know,
right?
I was gonna go to watch the faders,
faders,
fighting.
Uh,
ryan bader in la.
They're fighting at the forum,
but there's a,
there's a ufc that night I can't go.
I wanted to go see fate or fight live.
Yeah.
Never seen him fight live.
And I felt like that was a great fight in him versus bader.
Right.
That's a great fight to see live.
I've never,
I've never seen him fight live either.
I have a picture of me fader and tim crater like,
like just tim was fighting and fado is given me some advice on what to tell.
Tim,
what was he saying?
He was just,
he's just,
he's got to stay low and keep him away because he was fighting shale.
Right.
But this was before jail is jail and he's like,
he's,
he's wrestler like and somebody translating it to.
But um,
he's talking to me,
he's talking to,
he's talking to me and someone comes along and translate.
He's like,
he's got to stay low and keep them outside.
Keep him outside.
The guy translating sounds like this.
He said he's,
he says,
he said fado say keep him outside and stay low.
But just,
just having a conversation with that dude and sit next to him and he's not that
big of a guy is not that big of a guy.
So it was another guy who probably could be a middleweight.
Yeah,
fado is awesome though.
I mean if you see some of the middle weights that are in the ufc,
like ul,
ul was in your chair sitting right there and it looked like somebody dropped a,
a giant iron sculpture of a superhero and put it.
It doesn't even look like he doesn't look like a human.
He's so big dude.
He's like 2:20 plus just jacked everything neck,
shoulders back,
just jacked.
You're like,
that is a heavyweight.
Yeah.
You know,
if you sit him next to fate or he looks relaxed bigger way bigger than fader,
yet he fights a one 85,
but he's also so jacked and ripped and he's like my age.
It's incredible.
But he's not like.
He like,
you can be my age and be ripped like I am if I take off my shirt,
but I want to bash you.
Right.
Don't please don't.
Thank you.
But like the way he is,
he's ripped like a 25 year old.
He's ripped like a bodybuilder.
Yeah.
He's a freak of all freaks.
Like he like you see his body in the ring and you go,
first of all,
how did he make weight?
That's what I always think.
Like when even when he steps on the scale,
like back before we had the early wayans,
we had the weigh ins at the actual time of 4:00,
he would step on the scale and make weight,
you know,
like how is that 185 pounds?
It doesn't even make sense.
He looks like he's 200 pounds easy plus that,
that same thing happened in,
in the match with um,
conor and floyd when connor was getting on the scale.
Um,
mayweather's maybe this promoter was like,
he's not going to make the weight.
He's not gonna make the weIght,
but I don't know this.
There's some guys who,
you know,
especially the mma guys are bigger than boxers,
so it's one of those things like joelle has that down.
He's,
he's,
he is huge,
but at dehydration hits and that's probably why he sucks.
Lockhart talked about it.
Look at the size of that guys like 42 years old.
He's so jacked and unparalleled wrestling skills to,
oh shit.
Yoel romero versus david branches booked.
What does that click on?
That shit.
That might not be.
This is.
Could be older.
It might be new though.
I'll click on it.
Shit,
what do we got?
What are those?
Ufc on fox.
Oh yes,
yes.
Old.
So that never happened,
right?
Doesn't ever happen.
I don't remember it happening.
It didn't happen.
Hmm.
Typed in real elvers fader and there's a picture of the matching up 3,485 pound
division is kind of crazy because they're promising if style bender fights
anderson,
they're saying to anderson,
if you win,
you get a title shot and everybody else in divisions.
Like what,
what?
Like you think that that's like some trickery to get anderson to fight style
bender?
I,
that's exactly what I think it is.
That's exactly what I think I um,
does it they offer style bender title shot if he beats anderson.
Dan hook is,
I don't believe so.
And that a dad hooker hooker posted that on it,
on his,
on his instagram.
And I,
I like,
I like hooker and I just had to say something.
I was just like,
look,
we know that style.
And my thought was we know when style benton wins his fight because I really
believe that I wasn't going to win that fight.
When he wins this fight,
he's not going to get that title shot.
And I,
for me as a form of fighter and knowing who addison is and what he's done for
the sport and for the ufc,
I'm just like,
I feel like that's,
that's,
that's so disrespectful.
She asked me,
um,
that's mY opinion.
It's an opinion.
It's mine.
And I stand by that,
that,
you know,
we want to make this young guy star and we're going to,
we're goIng to sacrifice you to the wolf to get that done.
But anderson still feels like he can compete at the highest level.
We all go to feel like we could beat it if you put enough money in front of me,
I will,
I will fuck khabib up.
You put something in front of me that I really want.
I'm like,
that's the thing,
they give you a goal,
give you a time period to train and prepare for it.
Yeah.
Anderson's,
what,
43 now.
Yeah.
So,
so that's,
that's the thing,
out of the realm of possibilities the same age as well or close to it.
Yeah.
At least 40 years at least.
Yeah,
he's 41.
I mean,
it's not
the problem within.
I mean,
anderson,
we started failing drug tests like okay,
so he's probably struggling trying to get that edge,
you know,
trying to,
trying to recover and training.
So he's taking a bunch of weird supplements.
Some of them are tainted and I bet you if you go back to just
go back to what you used to do,
go back to what it was you did when you became the anniston silver that
everybody loves,
you know,
before,
before he got to the point where like before the forrest griffin fight,
because I believe that's when it started to decline for him.
Yeah.
He still looked good and he still,
it still performed well,
but he got away from,
from the fundamentals,
you know,
um,
and that forrest griffin fight,
he was able to take for us out without the fundamentals moving his head doing,
doing these weird things,
just popping back fundamentals.
What's the strongest thing in the game
for sure.
That fundamental.
The forrest griffin fights it.
An interesting example too though,
because forest had been kao twice in training for that fight,
but he had no business being in there.
They really.
And he just couldn't take shot,
which is another thing I want to talk to you about.
Tito.
Chuck,
as a guy who's retired,
who had an awesome career and you're watching that and you've seen a guy come
back at 50 and get stopped like that.
What does.
What did that do for you?
You kind of knew That.
Well,
I felt that chuck shouldn't be taking that fight right now.
Tito's been competing.
Tito's still in there and then when they stepped in,
as soon as they touched up,
it's like,
yeah,
chuck shouldn't be in here.
He looked does the first time he looked that much smaller than tito.
He didn't look the same size of the tito.
He didn't look comfortable.
He didn't look as coordinated.
Like chuck was always little quirky and awkward in his movement,
but he didn't even look like chuck liddell.
He looked like a shell of chocolate dell.
And if you see him hitting the pads,
like recent video of him hitting the pads,
did it look terrible?
Yeah.
He said he was just warming up like he had talked to brendan about it.
He says,
I always look bad when I'm warming up.
I'm like,
it's not just the look.
It looked like his balance was off work.
I,
I get that.
I would see if I would've saw that beforehand.
I still wouldn't put a whole lot of stock in that because like I remember being
a lock on 44 at hermes frank for the first time in the ufc and nick diaz was in
our locker room and niggas hitting pads and he's about to fight robby and he
didn't pads and he's like,
yeah,
I'm gonna knock this motherfucker out.
Yeah.
And I'm like not really hitting those pads.
Like he didn't,
he didn't look like he didn't look sharp,
he didn't look like getting poWer.
And then you went out there,
knocked ravi out.
It was just warming up though,
right?
like sometimes when guys warming up,
they'll just do just,
they're just trying to get their bodies.
Yeah.
They're not really trying to look like a fight or trying to look like sharp.
Like they're going to be inside the inside of the cage and yeah,
he just wanted to see if he could find that chuck chocolate,
dell hidden pads.
It's different.
It's different because it's like it.
His balance looks off,
his coordination looks off.
It just doesn't look.
It doesn't look good.
You know?
It just.
There's a.
Here it is.
Take a look at this.
Marsh says,
yeah.
Yeah.
Looks like it has no pop.
I mean it's crazy to watch.
Right?
It just looks like lucy,
How he throws that kick in and leans back afterwards.
It just looks like there's a real issue with someone who's had that many chaos.
You've been caled that many times,
like your brain's been scrambled that many times.
Like what is,
how is the,
the connection between your muscles in your mind which bumps nor neurologic.
Yeah.
It makes you uncomfortable,
right?
Yeah.
It does.
Like,
I mean,
and that's chuck.
Yeah.
I mean one of the greatest of all time.
I don't know.
I don't and I 49 also 50.
That's,
that's there's a point.
Yeah.
You know,
I almost feel like I would do it again for,
for certain.
I'm not trying to be a world champion,
I'm not trying to get to qbb or dustin and those guys,
you know,
um,
but like Joe lowe's on diego sanchez,
somebody that's like from the same era,
at least the part of the era that I was in,
somebody like that,
you know,
somebody who have respect for and it like it's going to be fun and some,
but like I'm not.
And I guess that's what tito and chuck is also chuck,
he beat him twice.
Yeah.
You know,
let's be inventories by knockout.
But the,
I think he just felt like you always had tito's number,
but this is the problem is like tito winds now,
right?
Like the guy who he never wanted to win now wins.
THe guy who wouldn't fight him when he was tHe champ.
now that was the winter,
like when it all said and done tito k odom.
And he kIlled him more soundly than chuck evekeo tito.
Because when chuck hailed tito,
he basically beat him down and then tito covered up.
But he was conscious,
right?
Like right.
Chuck chuck out,
he put them out and you know,
I mean,
it was a good shot for sure,
but it just seems like you're dealing with a guy whose,
whose brains are,
you know,
it's just,
he's been scrambled too many times.
YeaH.
Yeah.
Prizes.
They made that fight.
I am surprised that the commission that the fight happened.
Yes.
If that's what you mean.
Yeah.
I'm not surprised that that oscar de la hoya,
tito ortiz came together and said,
let's get chuck to fight me.
You know,
I'm not surprised about that at all.
Do you know that they said there was only like 25,000 pay per view.
But that's what I heard.
I kinda sucks.
So it's crazy.
horrible.
That's so low.
That must have cost everybody money.
LIke I have more instagram followers and it's a hard sell and the undercard
wasn't so good either.
It wasn't like there was a lot of like big names on the undercard that's gonna
draw people in where they're going to go,
well it's going to Be great fights no matter what.
no.
Yeah.
The,
the,
the undercard was not that great.
No,
no.
You know,
you saw the whole show.
No you didn't.
You didn't know who their windows.
But the,
um,
the undercard was not great.
Um,
and then the tito chuck fight,
chuck tito looks the,
the,
the
much better strike a much more accomplished striker in that fight.
And tito ortiz knocked out,
knocked out cHocolate.
Dell is that,
that's like a phrase I never thought I would hear and it'd be real,
but isn't it also the case of not just see tito remaining active and staying
competitive and exactly what it is.
It's that too,
but it's also a tito skills got better.
Yeah,
they definitely got better.
Jason pearls and awesome instructor.
I mean he's a fantastic boxing coach and he really tightened up tito's hands and
all these techniques over over the course of the years they were together and
the last time tito and chuck fought,
I phones hadn't been invented.
Yeah.
Think of that shit.
You know?
No iphones.
People using sidekicks.
Remember those,
you know,
where those things.
I remember that flip up the keyboard and everybody thought they were slick.
Yeah.
That was the last time they fought to different and myspace was a thing.
It was a different world man.
It's just um,
it's just sad to see it go down like that.
Where,
I mean it would be one thing if it was a good fight.
If tito looked like chuck chuck,
tito,
look good.
Chuck did not look good.
Right?
They both look good and they put on their best fight.
And then tito won up winning good for him.
But it wasn't that.
It was one guy was a,
just a shell shell of himself.
So what kind of fight for tito or rematch fatina would make sense to,
to that you think would sell?
Is there.
Is there one?
Tito versus jail will sell a little bit.
I mean he's been calling chill out saying I want to kick your ass,
but I think that was probably before the pay per view numbers came in and then
they'll like oscar tails.
Tails like,
nah,
he's probably got 15 voicemails on oscar's phone.
Oscar and call him back.
I'll asked,
is just sitting there going,
fuck tito ortiz.
Willing to postpone retirement to kick someone's ass again.
Yeah,
see,
but the thing is he's going to try to do that with oscar and golden boy.
And that's going to sell $13,000.
Pay per view buys.
Nobody's going to buy that.
Well,
I mean,
if,
if child gets the marketing,
somebody will buy it.
Look,
if they could figure out a real competitive fight for tito against someone who's
got a big name and I don't know who that big name would be,
but he could still sell some.
Did you see the um,
did you see somebody posted these?
I think cannot tell the raja posted these two videos of tito where it was like
somebody was asking him how does he feel about this fight with chuck?
And he's like,
I'm a much better fighting.
I was 12 years ago.
I'm much better fighter,
be bigger,
I'm stronger,
I'm younger,
I'm cities younger.
It gets a little flustered with said he wanted to outlive as kids too,
like to.
That's the worst thing you also said.
You also said,
he also said,
the guy's like,
so who's making the money off of the paper view?
Is it just you?
Is it all the fighters in the card or is it just you and chuck?
And he's like,
yeah,
it's me and myself and chuck,
we're going to make the money off of the peer view.
You know,
he just,
he just gets flooded and he just powered through these things.
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
it's not a talkers business fighters business.
Yeah.
It's weird.
You know,
you're asked,
asked to be several things and when a guy like conor comes along or a guy like
colby covington.
Oh,
that was the other thing I want to talk about.
They're talking about colby not fighting tyron for the title now.
And then eastman leap frogging over colby,
who's the interim champ?
Didn't they strip colby?
Did they strip him?
I believe he called the stripped maybe.
Yeah,
maybe they did strip.
Um,
which is also weird.
Which is weird because like,
that should've been tyrants first fight back from that shoulder surgery,
you know,
that's what the interim is for,
right?
Yeah.
I mean,
that's,
if it's not,
then what's an interim for.
Unless if they stripped him,
the only reason why I could see saying uzma,
but also that's another thing where I think it's probably negotiation tactics.
It's like the nate diaz dust employee a thing.
I remember looking this up and someone was trying to correct me last time I did,
it was supposed to be,
which I don't know if it actually happened when that fight happened with tyron
until when that fight happened,
he was supposed to be stripped,
but he's on the website.
He still listed as the interim champ.
Well,
it's a good move to keep them in the interim champ if they decide to fight
because then the champ versus champ,
you know,
if they do decide to make that fight,
I feel like on paper,
at least financially,
it's a good fight because uh,
like colby talks so much shit.
It's like it's worth,
it's worth putting together just for that because people don't know huisman is
as much,
but it was a nightmare for anybody.
He is the biggest,
I believe,
biggest threat to tyron right now.
Solid wrestling,
striking conditioning.
Everything super strong.
Yeah,
and just has been on a tear and has gotten better with every fight has been
proven.
Has gone through the trial by fire inside the octagon.
Exactly like colby has.
Colby has the wrestling,
I'm submission awareness.
At least his offensive submissions aren't the best,
but he can finish you and his striking is competent,
but he has no power.
He's not going to hurt tyra in term title holder.
Okay.
Yeah.
So they didn't strip them to decide to keep them,
but who knows,
they might have just not Kevin Mcdonald,
the website.
He was one of my students.
Really?
Yeah.
Wow,
that's great.
It's great ref.
Yeah,
he's a good rough.
Um,
the uh,
the colby thing is interesting.
You know,
it's like his fight again,
hafael dot sohn.
Joe's like anybody who thought he wasn't for real,
like you see that fit,
you beat the shit out.
Dos anjos his conditioning is incredible.
I mean that is,
that is one of the big things about that dude.
This is conditioning.
It's off the charts.
He doesn't get tired.
It does not get tired.
He's a fucking animal.
Yeah.
So that's the thing that makes that fight interesting.
With tire.
Can he push tyron?
But kenny survive.
That's the thing.
That's the big thing.
See dos anjos is more of a volume striker at one 70.
He's not going to knock those bigger guys out.
But tyron and knock on anybody.
So this is a.
I want
to see that fight.
And the thing with colby,
like the last time I trained with him,
it's been about a year,
but at that point he was hard to miss.
You know,
for me,
I know I'm a striker but I'm tiring.
Like tyrons got good.
Chris boxing put,
he hit so hard,
so strong.
He's so
fast,
like a straight right hand.
I remember when he fought,
I'm carlos condit,
he hit them with a lead right hand and I was just like
whoa.
Somebody like removed some friends from that.
From reality.
He crossed over so fast like this distance,
like he closed the distance so quick.
He's explosive.
He's so fast.
I don't know.
I tyron is a real champion,
you know what I mean?
He's a real champion and not getting the credit that he deserves for a long time
and that bothers him,
but he's in a
handful of the greatest wall towards of all time now,
in my opinion.
You got matt hughes who's a legend and of course george st pierre,
robbie lawler and then tyrone who knocked out robbie lawler.
I mean in my opinion,
he's right up there and then as these winds pile up,
you make more of a case of him being the best welterweight ever.
Yeah,
tiring.
With that being said,
he's.
He's beaten a lot of the guys in the division,
but he needs,
like you said earlier,
he needs a fight like a gsp.
He needs some something where somebody else's established because with him
coming in and taken out robbie and and all these other young guys,
they proven amongst themselves and amongst each other,
but a lot of the,
like you said,
nobody knows.
Come on with simon and huseman.
He's.
He's a threat to everybody.
Everybody,
you know,
he's been wanting and he's been wonderful,
but he's been wanting down until he wants.
He wants everybody because he wants a shot at the belt and um,
I believe for real,
he's the biggest,
biggest threat to tiring,
but I'm tyron could win that fight also can win it convincingly and then it
means nothing to the,
to the world who tyron wants to respect what he's done as the champion.
Yeah.
In that case,
that's one of the reasons why the fight with colby makes the most sense.
I think it would be the most controversial,
highest profile because colby,
we'll talk mad shit.
Time will get really angry and if he beats him and smashes him then it steps up
him and puts him in a.
And then in the meantime,
I mean tills not going to fight at one 70 anymore.
Tills moved up to one 85.
Okay.
So like,
but you still have a plethora of killers in the welterweight division.
I mean you can make a lot of match ups,
but the colby fight,
the colby fight also could help tire and get over to.
Because colby is going to talk a lot of shit and some of it's disrespectful and
people,
people like to see those guys get stopped.
It's true.
So that's,
that's that.
Maybe that's what that's like to see those guys get stopped.
Not just get beat the tire and win that fight.
Yeah,
for the most part he has to stop colby because colby is not going to quit.
And in the fourth round he's gonna.
He's gonna step on the gas.
Tyron can't keep up.
Then it's going to be a problem.
I got david goggins here to nice max amount.
Anything else before we get out of here?
The only other thing was the ketone meals.
Like those things are awesome.
They want to make an,
an elk meal and they want it.
They want to talk to you about,
about,
about it.
We'll talk about that afterwards.
So what,
what does that company,
what is a ketone,
ketone bodies,
ketone bodies and ketone meals.
Um,
and um,
you can look them up online.
He told me you're working with them.
Yes.
They,
they've been sponsoring me and him send me good stuff.
To my house.
Beautiful.
We'll talk either.
Thank you sir.
Always a pleasure.
Pfl new year's eve.
New year's eve.
Nbc sports.
Check us out by everybody.